Alice:有啊
Alice:哈喽
Alice: Hello
Alice:在弄我的小狗
Alice: I'm playing with my puppy
Alice:这个还有面包哎
Alice: There's also some bread here
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Jake:你有擦眼镜的布吗
Jake: Do you have a cloth to clean glasses?
Alice:没有
Alice: No
Lucia: 这是我们之前拆开了一个
Lucia: This is one we opened earlier
Lucia: 什么拆眼镜
Lucia: What, clean glasses?
Lucia: 我这个眼镜
Lucia: My glasses
Lucia: 这镜片有点太太雾
Lucia: The lens is a bit foggy
Jake:在一个我放到了一个盒子里
Jake: I put it in a box
Jake:不知道是谁的盒子
Jake: Not sure whose box it is
Jake:不是你的
Jake: It's not yours
Jake:核心是你的吗
Jake: Is the core yours?
Alice:嗯我的盒吗我找一下在哪
Alice: Hmm, is it my box? Let me check where it is
Jake:你的盒我能看一下吗
Jake: Can I take a look at your box?
Jake:哎你的盒
Jake: Hey, your box
Jake:好吧你的盒在这
Jake: Okay, your box is here
Lucia: 我的盒在楼上
Lucia: My box is upstairs
Jake:那不应该呀
Jake: That shouldn't be right
Lucia: 安康鱼
Lucia: Anglerfish
Jake:稍等啊把这丢了先
Jake: Hold on, let's throw this away first
Lucia: 这个是谁的乐队的标志啊
Lucia: Whose band logo is this?
Alice: ：应该
Lucia: 这个安康鱼
Lucia: This anglerfish
Shure: 他自己的
Shure: His own
Lucia: 他自己的他乐队后来改名了
Lucia: His own, his band later changed its name
Lucia: 后来改名了
Alice:哈哈哈看他的技
Alice: Hahaha, look at his skills
Lucia: 他在忽悠我
Lucia: He's tricking me
Shure: 这个听过了 ，听过现场第二天就发烧
Shure: I've heard it, after hearing it live I got a fever the next day
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 我是去炸开了，完就发烧了
Shure: I went and exploded, then I got a fever
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:这个这个在地上捡着
Jake: This, this was picked up off the ground
Jake:但是不一定干净
Jake: But it might not be clean
Jake:试试
Jake: Try it
Lucia:   ：再拿个餐巾纸
Lucia: Get another napkin
Lucia: 不过一般来说
Lucia: But generally speaking
Lucia:  ：根据我戴眼镜的经验餐巾纸擦不干净
Lucia: Based on my experience with wearing glasses, tissues don't clean well.
Jake:好对
Jake: That's right.
Jake:会带电
Jake: They carry static.
Lucia: 而且会不会磨到这个镜片啊
Lucia: And won't they scratch the lenses?
Lucia: 我的餐巾纸
Lucia: My tissues...
Lucia:  ：哦真的吗那我就放心了
Lucia: Oh really? Then I'm relieved.
Lucia: 哈哈有您这句话我就放心了
Lucia: Haha, with your assurance, I'm relieved.
Alice:这是可以说的吗
Alice: Is it okay to say this?
Jake:眼镜只认镜片
Jake: Glasses only recognize lenses.
Jake:不值钱镜片
Jake: Cheap lenses.
Alice:镜片值钱
Alice: Lenses are expensive.
Jake:对镜框值钱
Jake: Yes, frames are expensive.
Jake:咱要不把镜片摘了吧
Jake: Should we take out the lenses?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:咱这也没度数
Jake: These don't have a prescription anyway.
Lucia: 哦这镜片能摘
Lucia: Oh, you can take out the lenses?
Alice: 可以摘吗
Alice: Can you take them out?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Alice:录一个去镜片的什么活动
Alice: Record an event for removing lenses or something.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 你又不太好摘
Lucia: It's not easy to take out.
Jake:对好摘但是不好摘
Jake: Yes, easy to take out but not easy to take out.
Jake:对能摘但是不好摘对
Jake: Yes, you can take them out but it's not easy.
Lucia: OK OK那要不还是算了吧
Lucia: OK OK, maybe we should just forget it.
Lucia: 这个掰掰个对算了咱就哎
Lucia: Let's just forget it, yeah.
Jake:对算了哎
Jake: Yeah, let's forget it.
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:对还有一个就是我们
Jake: Yes, there's also the thing that
Jake:就是你昨天挂掉的
Jake: you accidentally hung up yesterday.
Jake:原因是你可能一不小心碰到了这个
Jake: The reason might be you accidentally touched this.
Alice:这个是什么
Alice: What is this?
Jake:对就是这个
Jake: Yes, it's this.
Jake:是这个是允许拍摄
Jake: This means recording is allowed.
Jake:这是不允许拍摄
Jake: This means recording is not allowed.
Jake:就是你现在
Jake: So if you
Jake:如果比方说是你如果后悔了
Jake: for example, if you regret it,
Jake:这一段你不想拍
Jake: and you don't want to record this part.
Jake:然后你就咔之前全部删掉了
Jake: Then you can just delete everything before.
Alice:直接就是快捷键的
Alice: Just use the shortcut key.
Jake:对快捷键的对一键
Jake: Yeah, for the shortcut, it's one-click.
Jake:删除一键删除
Jake: Delete, one-click delete.
Lucia: 一键删除
Lucia: One-click delete.
Jake:嗯昨天就一键删除了
Jake: Yeah, I used one-click delete yesterday.
Jake:就是没有拍到你被狗咬
Jake: We didn't catch you getting bitten by the dog.
Jake:他没有拍到你被狗咬的这个镜头
Jake: They didn't get the shot of you getting bitten by the dog.
Alice:一哈哈哈
Alice: Haha!
Lucia: 你是跟我应该拍到的
Lucia: You were supposed to catch that with me.
Jake:你你自己拍到了
Jake: You, you caught it yourself.
Jake:你没有一键删除
Jake: You didn't use one-click delete.
Lucia: 现在好像看不出来了
Jake:好打成功
Jake: Alright, successful hit.
Alice:我觉得今天下午我们应该要布置了
Alice: I think we should set things up this afternoon.
Lucia: 我们这个是今天没删吗还在删吗？
Lucia: Are we still deleting today or is it done?
Lucia: 客气，当我没说吧。
Lucia: Never mind, just ignore what I said.
Jake:反应了一会
Jake: Took a while to react.
Jake:话音未落
Jake: Before you finished speaking,
Jake:他自己就删掉了
Jake: he had already deleted it himself.
Jake:难道你也开了一键删除
Jake: Did you also use one-click delete?
Lucia: 啊哈哈哎
Lucia: Ah, haha!
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Alice:对了我的删了没有
Alice: By the way, did I delete mine?
Alice:看我一下哦
Alice: Take a look for me.
Jake:你删了你们都删了
Jake: You deleted it, you all did.
Jake:我们要做几条狗啊
Jake: How many dogs do we need to make?
Alice:我已经做完了
Alice: I already finished mine.
Alice:我的狗
Alice: My dog.
Jake:我们每人做一条狗放在门口
Jake: Each of us will make one dog and place it at the door.
：大家可以每人做一个
: Everyone can make one.
Lucia: 然后给它起个名字
Lucia: And then give it a name.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Alice:我的叫
Alice: I'll name mine...
Alice:乐乐吧比较快乐他的样子
Alice: Lele, because it looks happy.
Alice:有人的小名叫乐乐吗
Alice: Does anyone have the nickname Lele?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没有明天04
Lucia: Not yet, maybe tomorrow.
Jake:暂时还没有
Jake: Not for now.
Alice:但其实他还没有完全完成
Alice: But actually, it's not completely done yet.
Jake:还差点啥
Jake: What's still missing?
Alice:因为剪这个实在是太费手了
Alice: Cutting this is really hard on my hands.
Alice:你没看见他这个是一整条
Alice: Didn't you see his is a whole strip?
Jake:哦他这个火车小狗火车
Jake: Oh, it's a little train, a puppy train.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈火车狗
Alice: Hahaha, a train puppy.
Alice:我想给我的狗别个大花
Alice: I want to put a big flower on my dog.
Alice:哼哼哼
Alice: Hmph hmph hmph.
Jake:模范狗狗
Jake: Model dog.
Alice:给他扭个花戴上
Alice: Twist a flower for him to wear.
Lucia: 我发现我的那个珠串今天就能到
Lucia: I found out my bead string can arrive today.
Lucia: 但是欧根纱好像明天才能到
Lucia: But the organza seems to arrive tomorrow.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:我也有一个明天到
Alice: I also have one arriving tomorrow.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:然后我那个挂布到了
Alice: And my hanging cloth arrived.
Alice:但是我正在想办法把它挂起来
Alice: But I'm trying to figure out how to hang it up.
Alice:我觉得不太好挂
Alice: I think it's hard to hang.
Lucia: 最尴尬的是我发现我忘记买灯珠了
Lucia: The most awkward thing is I realized I forgot to buy light beads.
Lucia: 所以即使我们做出了水母
Lucia: So even if we make the jellyfish,
Lucia: 灯他也亮不了
Lucia: the light won't shine.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah, ah.
Lucia: 但我们可以认为他是一个水母
Lucia: But we can consider it as a jellyfish.
Lucia: 没有灯
Lucia: Without light.
Lucia: 去掉灯字
Lucia: Remove the word "light".
Jake:就拿手电筒照一照
Jake: Just shine a flashlight on it.
Lucia: 也可以理论上说
Lucia: That works theoretically.
Lucia: 比如说像这样
Lucia: For example, like this.
Lucia: 我觉得这个瓶子还行
Lucia: I think this bottle is okay.
Lucia: 他这要是弧度更
Lucia: If its curve was
Lucia: 就是slope更陡一点就好了
Lucia: steeper, it would be better.
Jake:更短一点就好
Jake: A bit shorter would be good.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Alice: 那你把它放起来吧
Alice: Then you can put it up.
Lucia: 就
Lucia: Just
Lucia: 本来应该在这里面放一个那种小灯珠
Lucia: originally, there should be a small light bead in it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:那是得像那种
Jake: It should be like that.
Jake:呃那叫啥呢
Jake: Uh, what's it called?
Jake:苏打水
Jake: Soda water.
Jake:或者可以买
Jake: Or you could buy
Jake:其实就是很品的那种
Jake: actually, just a high-quality one.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:是果汁那种
Jake: It's like fruit juice.
Lucia: 就是圆一点的就
Lucia: It's the round kind, right?
Lucia: 呃怎么说呢
Lucia: Uh, how to say...
Jake:你觉得圆可乐吗
Jake: Do you think round cola?
Lucia: 就是网上那种
Lucia: Like the ones online.
Lucia: 就是废物利用的那种教程
Lucia: It's like those tutorials on reusing stuff.
Lucia: 他用的是那种奶茶盖的可乐瓶
Lucia: He used a milk tea lid for the cola bottle.
Lucia: 可乐瓶那个应该也还行
Lucia: A cola bottle would work too.
Lucia: 我觉得元气森林那个弧度就还不错
Lucia: I think the curve of the Genki Forest bottle is pretty good.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 我们如果用小瓶子做的话
Lucia: If we use a small bottle.
Lucia: 它就会比较小
Lucia: It would be quite small.
Lucia: 元气森林
Lucia: Genki Forest.
Lucia: 我觉得这就还可以剪到这个位置
Lucia: I think we can cut it to this point.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:好我决定给我的狗做几个
Alice: Alright, I decided to make a few for my dog.
Alice:这样带个花不是白的
Alice: So with flowers, not just white.
Alice:哈哈哈就是这样带我一个
Alice: Hahaha, just like this, include me.
Jake:那就戴一下呗
Jake: Then just wear it.
Alice:是是弄这几朵呢还是给他弄个花花
Alice: Should I make a few flowers or just a flower crown?
Lucia: 花环
Lucia: A flower crown.
Alice:嗯对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Alice:我们是没有透明胶带
Lucia: 好像是没有
Lucia: Seems like we don't.
Alice:没事，那种胶带也可以
Alice: It's okay, that tape will work too.
Lucia: 这好像是
Lucia: Seems like it is.
Lucia: 我昨天压那花压一天能压压成型
Lucia: I pressed that flower all day yesterday to shape it.
Alice:嗯有点想打开看看但是
Alice: Hmm, I kinda want to open and check but...
Lucia: 有点想打开看看但是
Lucia: Kinda want to open and check but...
Alice:哎昨天那个白色的胶带还在吗
Alice: Hey, is that white tape from yesterday still here?
Alice:是不是后来又对对对
Alice: Did we use it later on, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 双面胶那可能健康拿走了吧
Lucia: The double-sided tape might have been taken by Health.
Alice:那就先用这个吧
Alice: Let's use this for now.
Alice:啊啊保佑
Alice: Ah, bless it.
Alice:就是不好用
Alice: It's just not working well.
Alice:有这个这是
Alice: Here's this one, this is...
Lucia: 我们中午吃什么
Lucia: What are we having for lunch?
Alice:卤煮
Alice: Braised stew.
Alice:双面胶
Alice: Double-sided tape.
Lucia: 它是一种类似于冒菜的东西吗
Lucia: Is it something like hotpot?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Lucia: 它不是
Lucia: It's not.
Alice:做法上可能是近亲哎
Alice: The way it's made is kind of similar.
Alice:怎么没有胶呢
Alice:胶带在哪里
Alice: Where's the tape?
Alice:剪刀也找不到
Alice: Can't find the scissors either.
Lucia: 这真的啊
Lucia: Really?
Lucia: 好难掰啊
Lucia: This is so hard to break.
Alice:没有胶带罢了
Alice: It's just that there's no tape.
Lucia: 哎你看掰这种水果需要策略
Lucia: Hey, you see, breaking this kind of fruit needs strategy.
Lucia: 你学会了吗
Lucia: Did you learn it?
Lucia: 哎呀喂
Lucia: Oh no.
Lucia: 你学废了吗
Lucia: Did you get it?
Lucia: 他没有
Lucia: He didn't.
Alice:粘不上
Alice: Can't stick it.
Alice:小狗狗的鼻子小狗狗的嘴
Alice: Little dog's nose, little dog's mouth.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Nicous: 拜拜拜拜
Nicous:  我们正在发行货币
Lucia: 我需要一个充电宝
Lucia: I need a power bank.
Lucia: 不行不能拔这个
Lucia: No, can't unplug this.
Lucia: 这连着是连摄像头的啊
Lucia: This is connected to the camera.
Lucia: let me check
Lucia: Let me check.
Lucia: 哦对我还有一个
Lucia: Oh right, I have another one.
Lucia: 快递到了
Lucia: The package arrived.
Lucia: 哎呀我的芍药终于响开了
Lucia: Oh my, my peony finally bloomed.
Lucia: 不知道这个
Lucia: I wonder if this...
Lucia: 水里的营养够不够支撑到他想开
Lucia: If the nutrients in the water are enough for it to bloom.
Lucia: 感觉我们退房的时候
Lucia: Feels like when we check out,
Lucia: 收拾这个房子会是个大工程
Lucia: cleaning this place will be a huge task.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Alice:你买回家的票了吗
Alice: Did you buy your ticket home?
Lucia: 嗯还没不过票挺多的
Lucia: Not yet, but there should be plenty of tickets.
Lucia: 应该
Lucia: I guess.
Lucia: 我回去要不然就坐高铁回去
Lucia: If I go back, I'll probably take the high-speed train.
Lucia: 行我来的时候是坐的我
Lucia: Yeah, I took a plane when I came.
Lucia: 来时坐的飞机
Lucia: I flew here.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 就忙什么
Lucia: So busy.
Lucia: 我们现在
Lucia: We're now...
Lucia: 我们现在在忙什么啊
Lucia: What are we busy with right now?
其他人：就是我说 就是
Others: Just like I said, just
Lucia: 你说项目结束之后
Lucia: You said after the project ends
Lucia: 嗯我应该暂时在北京
Lucia: Yeah, I should be in Beijing for a while
Lucia: 没什么事
Lucia: Not much going on
Lucia: 本来想着可能会有点事
Lucia: I thought there might be something
Lucia: 但是最近两天我看了下
Lucia: But recently, I checked
其他人：你呢
Others: And you?
Lucia: 好像不太需要继续待在这
Lucia: Seems like I don't need to stay here anymore
Alice:我我有事
Alice: I have something to do
其他人：你有事嗯
Others: You have something to do, huh?
Alice:咋了
Alice: What's up?
Lucia: 要聚餐吗
Lucia: Should we have a dinner together?
Alice:要聚餐吗
Alice: Should we have a dinner together?
其他人：我在考虑点大问题
Others: I'm thinking about some big problems
Alice:比如说
Alice: Like what?
其他人：昨天发现三亚的房子他妈太便宜了
Others: Yesterday I found out the houses in Sanya are damn cheap
其他人：一天200啊
Others: Only 200 a day
Alice:大理也便宜
Alice: Dali is cheap too
Alice:大理就是一整个民宿
Alice: Dali has entire homestays
Lucia: 我可以啊
Lucia: I'm okay with it
Lucia: 我没啥事
Lucia: I don't have much going on
Lucia: 因为我现在是该片
Lucia: Because right now I'm editing
Lucia: 所以只不过我就是因为我家在西安
Lucia: So it's just that my home is in Xi'an
Lucia: 我就是我毕业的
Lucia: Where I graduated
Lucia: 所以我现对
Lucia: So right now, I'm usually not in Beijing
Lucia: 所以我现在就是平常不在北京
Lucia: So if it's not immediately connected
Lucia: 所以假如说不是即刻连着
Lucia: If it's not something urgent
Lucia: 就要搞那个什么的话
Lucia: I need to go back home first
Lucia: 我就需要先回下家
Lucia: Otherwise renting a place in Beijing is such a hassle
Lucia: 不然还在北京租房子麻烦的很
Lucia: Otherwise it's really troublesome to rent a place in Beijing
Alice:所以三亚有什么规划吗
Alice: So, do you have any plans for Sanya?
其他人：是他让我的破房啊
Others: It's about that broken house of mine
Lucia: 破房
Lucia: Broken house
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
其他人：是不是
Others: Isn't it?
Lucia:  我又让你破防了
其他人：你让我老板破防
Tasha: 是的我让杨老板也破防
Tasha: Yeah, I let Jake down with the broken house
其他人 ：他确实让杨老板破房
Others: He did let Jake down with the broken house
Lucia: 我想问一下他破什么房了
Lucia: I want to ask, what did he break?
Lucia: 杨老板轻轻的破房了
Lucia: Jake lightly broke the room.
其他人：因为有没有可能
Others: Because, is it possible...
其他人：有没有可能
Others: Is it possible...
其他人：那边10天只要2,000块钱大别墅
Others: There, you can get a big villa for just 2,000 yuan for 10 days.
Lucia: 这么便宜
Lucia: So cheap.
Alice:那大一个月才只要1,000多呢
Alice: A big one there is only around 1,000 a month.
Tasha: 但是老板离那个新加坡近
Tasha: But the boss is closer to Singapore.
其他人：但是他新加坡飞到三亚只要3小时
Others: But it only takes 3 hours to fly from Singapore to Sanya.
Lucia: 只要30块钱哦哈哈哈
Lucia: Only 30 yuan, haha.
其他人 ：3小时
Others: 3 hours.
Alice:3小时
Alice: 3 hours.
其他人 ：他说他飞回北京先飞到上海，再从上海到北京
Others: He said he flies back to Beijing, then from Shanghai to Beijing.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Lucia: 哦他这转的机啊缩嘎
Lucia: Oh, he's transferring flights, I see.
Alice:浅浅破防了
Alice:那这个房间呢
Alice: What about this room?
Tasha: 2000  1天
Tasha: 2,000 a day.
Alice: 一天啊
Alice: A day?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
其他人：1,300一天啊
Others: 1,300 a day.
Alice:1,300一天
Alice: 1,300 a day.
其他人：听说1500好像是
Others: I heard it's 1,500.
Alice:1,500一天
Alice: 1,500 a day.
Tasha: 他说用了2万
Tasha: He said he used 20,000.
其他人：对算押金
Others: Yeah, that's the deposit.
Tasha: 哦算押金
Tasha: Oh, that's the deposit.
Alice:破防了
Alice:丢盔弃甲破大防了
Alice: Lost everything and broke the room.
Lucia: 可能因为是北京的缘故吧
Lucia: Maybe because it's in Beijing.
Tasha: 已经决定转战三亚了他们
Tasha: They have decided to move to Sanya.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Great, great.
Lucia: 刚好我没去过三亚
Lucia: I haven't been to Sanya yet.
Lucia: 如果你们到时候那个啥的话可以
Lucia: If you guys do that, I can...
Lucia: 我可以我可以再去玩
Lucia: I can go and have fun again.
Lucia: 我今年8月份之前应该都有空哈哈
Lucia: I should be free until August this year, haha.
其他人：这个逼搞不起来啊
Others: This isn't working out.
Alice:卧槽啊他一直他妈网络问题嗱
Alice: Damn, he's always having network issues.
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake:咋给抢了呀
Jake: How did it get taken?
其它人：我唔攞啦
Jake:哎不行啊
Jake: Hey, that's not okay.
Jake:为了10年之后的10个亿
Jake: For the 1 billion in 10 years.
Alice:你怎么了
Alice: What's wrong with you?
Alice:薇薇好酸
Alice: Tasha, it's so sour.
Tasha: 好酸
Tasha: So sour.
Jake:对必须搞
Jake: Yeah, we have to do it.
Alice:你说你弄的啥呀
Alice: What did you make?
Jake:今天必须搞
Jake: We have to do it today.
Lucia: 10个小目标
Lucia: 10 small goals.
Tasha: 他楼上冲的黑咖啡
Tasha: The black coffee he brewed upstairs.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha!
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈咖
Alice: Hahaha coffee.
Alice:啡可以苦不能酸
Alice: Coffee can be bitter but not sour.
Tasha: 是的，我加点奶吧
Tasha: Yes, I'll add some milk.
Lucia: 我头好疼啊
Lucia: I have a headache.
Lucia: 啊没事
Lucia: Ah, it's nothing.
Lucia: 可能是打针的问题
Lucia: Maybe it's because of the injection.
Jake:二次花多少钱啊
Jake: How much did the second round cost?
其他人：这个这应该抓好要化一点点小
Others: This should be handled carefully, a little bit.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:他这有墙吗你这有墙吗
Jake: Is there a wall here? Do you have a wall here?
Jake:你这翻吗
Jake: Are you flipping this?
Jake:你这global
Jake: Are you global?
Jake:你是global吗是global
Jake: Are you global? Are you global?
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Let's just do it this way.
Tasha: 杨老板
Tasha: Jake.
Tasha: 我们今天要再采购一次
Tasha: We need to shop again today.
Tasha: 然后再做甜品
Tasha: And then make desserts.
Tasha: 牛奶也没了
Tasha: We're out of milk too.
Jake:那就买呗
Jake: Then buy it.
Tasha: 那是去超市还是直接手机上买
Tasha: Should we go to the supermarket or buy it online?
Lucia: 你这个单子好好看呀
Lucia: Your list looks great.
Jake:我想想
Jake: Let me think.
Jake:一会问一下大家有没有别的要买
Jake: I'll ask everyone if there's anything else to buy later.
Jake:或者比方说你没到的东西
Jake: Or for example, something you didn't get.
Jake:如果多的话直接出去买
Jake: If there's a lot, we'll just go out and buy it.
Jake:去超市买
Jake: Let's buy it at the supermarket.
Jake:威亚还有什么没到的东西吗
Jake: Wei Ya, is there anything that hasn't arrived yet?
Tasha: 我的欧根纱和一个就是镭射海光纸
Tasha: My organza and a roll of laser holographic paper.
Jake:东西能买到吗
Jake: Can we buy those things?
Lucia: 不知道哈哈
Lucia: No idea, haha.
Lucia: 我们可以在外面多逛逛
Lucia: We can look around outside more.
Lucia: 让我看看
Lucia: Let me check.
Lucia: 如果如果时间允许
Lucia: If time permits.
Jake:这可以商量商量时间
Jake: We can discuss the timing.
Jake:看看时间不多了
Jake: It looks like we don't have much time left.
Lucia: 这明天明天活动的话
Lucia: For tomorrow's event,
Lucia: 我们是不是得把这俩客厅收拾收拾
Lucia: Shouldn't we tidy up these two living rooms?
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 我 见不得人哈
Tasha: I can't bear to see people here, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我们这个客厅现在状态
Lucia: Hahaha, our living room's current state.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 会不会过于真实了
Lucia: Is it too realistic?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:我们压花怎么说
Jake: What about our pressed flowers?
Jake:我们压花现在是什么
Jake: How are our pressed flowers now?
Lucia: 压完了，昨天的压花可以取了吗
Lucia: They're done, can we take out yesterday's pressed flowers?
Katrina: 里面有蜜蜂哎
Katrina: There are bees inside.
Lucia: 哎没有我刚打开的
Lucia: No, I just opened it.
Katrina: 我们去把它晒一会太阳应该
Katrina: Let's put them in the sun for a while.
Lucia: 可以好的
Lucia: Okay, sure.
Katrina: 但是昨天下午才压应该还不够
Katrina: But since we pressed them yesterday afternoon, it's probably not enough yet.
Lucia: 我刚才就是把它打开
Lucia: I just opened them,
Lucia: 之后在想能不能就是整个拆开
Lucia: Then I thought about taking them apart.
Lucia: 但我又不敢
Lucia: But I didn't dare,
Lucia: 所以我又没拆
Lucia: So I didn't.
Jake:然后这些花是放回卧室是吗还是搁这
Jake: Should we put these flowers back in the bedroom or leave them here?
Katrina: 可以放回卧室
Katrina: We can put them back in the bedroom.
Lucia: 可以放回卧室吧
Lucia: Yeah, let's put them back in the bedroom.
Jake:那就放回卧室吧
Jake: Then let's put them back in the bedroom.
Katrina: 今天等一会下午看一下有没有压
Katrina: Check again in the afternoon to see if they're pressed.
Katrina: 好的有的
Katrina: Okay, got it.
Katrina: 那个花瓣可能就好了
Katrina: The petals should be ready.
Katrina: 就可以自己做
Katrina: You can make your own,
Katrina: 就明信片
Katrina: Like postcards.
Jake:那我们先把这个花给放回去
Jake: Let's put these flowers back first.
Jake:让客厅看起来东西少一点
Jake: So the living room looks less cluttered.
Alice:自己的屋里
Alice: In your own room.
Jake:自个卧室
Jake: In your bedroom.
Katrina: 好好
Katrina: Okay, okay.
Katrina: 把花拿走是吧
Katrina: Take the flowers away, right?
Katrina: 清一下桌子
Katrina: Clear the table.
Lucia: 这好像是我的
Lucia: This seems to be mine.
Lucia: 我想给他换换水可以换吗
Lucia: I want to change the water, can I?
Alice:换吧
Alice: Go ahead.
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Lucia: 换了他不会他不会他不会嘎吧
Lucia: If I change it, it won't, it won't, it won't die, right?
Alice:不会
Alice:他是自然的老去
Alice: It will naturally age.
Lucia: 那我到洗手间去换啊
Lucia: Then I'll go to the bathroom to change it.
Lucia: 您在切芒果
Lucia: You're cutting mangoes.
Lucia: 让我们看看今天的转化率有多少
Lucia: Let's see what the conversion rate is today.
Jake:好称一下
Jake: Okay, let's weigh it.
Tasha: 怎么安装它呢
Tasha: How do we install this?
Alice:哎哟妈呀
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 明天就是最后一天了
Tasha: Tomorrow is the last day.
Alice:明天到了第二天
Alice: Tomorrow is the day after.
Alice:周一不是还有干嘛什么的
Alice: Isn't there something on Monday too?
Tasha: 周一好像就是收尾了
Tasha: Monday seems to be the wrap-up.
Alice:你周一晚上走还是周二
Alice: Are you leaving Monday night or Tuesday?
Jake:你在哪 儿啊？
Jake: Where are you?
其他人 ：在门口那个
Others: At the door.
Tasha: 嗯不太知道呢
Tasha: Um, not sure yet.
Jake:我看到有个53号啊
Jake: I see number 53.
Jake:好呃别别别别动啊53号呃
Jake: Okay, uh, don't move, number 53, uh.
Tasha: 我也没想好
Tasha: I haven't decided yet.
Alice:（歌声）嗯嗯
Alice: (singing) Hmm hmm.
Jake:然后您可能得
Jake: Then you might have to...
Alice:我看看
Alice: Let me see.
Tasha: 没事我可能要问问客服了
Tasha: It's okay, I might need to ask customer service.
Jake:我我们是31号就是
Jake: We are number 31.
Alice:这怎么那么小的眼啊
Alice: Why is this so tiny?
Alice:看不懂
Alice: I don't understand.
Alice:平时喜欢去探店吗
Alice: Do you like visiting stores usually?
Tasha: 我吗
Tasha: Me?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 我觉得探店的那种店应该会比较贵吧
Tasha: I think the stores you visit like that are pretty expensive.
Tasha: 就是价格
Tasha: I mean the prices.
Alice:呃不一定
Alice: Uh, not necessarily.
Alice:不过北京也没有特别便宜的
Alice: But Beijing isn't particularly cheap either.
Alice:一般来说就是就算同一
Alice: Generally speaking, even if it's the same
Alice:个品质的北京也会比周边地区贵一点
Alice: quality, Beijing will be a bit more expensive than surrounding areas.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 感觉探的店都是网红店
Tasha: Feels like all the places we visit are internet-famous spots.
Tasha: 网红店就会偏贵一些
Tasha: Internet-famous spots tend to be pricier.
Alice: 是的
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:但是我
Alice: But I
Alice:我也不知道北京有那种什么小众的
Alice: I don't really know of any niche places in Beijing
Alice:那种好吃的店
Alice: that are really good.
Alice:一般小众的话容易开不下去吧
Alice: Generally, niche places don't last long, right?
Tasha: 这个样子
Tasha: I see.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 还蛮可爱的
Tasha: That's pretty cute.
Tasha: 懂了
Tasha: Got it.
Alice:对
Alice: Yep.
Tasha: 懂啦
Tasha: Got it.
Tasha: 咚啦
Tasha: 懂啦懂啦
Tasha: Got it, got it.
Alice:你五一确定好了吗
Alice: Have you finalized your plans for May Day?
Tasha: 没呢
Tasha: Not yet.
Alice:票还没有确定
Alice: Haven't secured tickets yet?
Tasha: 也没抢到
Tasha: Haven't gotten them yet.
Tasha: 行吧要不要去吃饭
Tasha: Alright, should we go eat?
Tasha: 饭到了刚刚
Tasha: The food just arrived.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:我们是不能在墙上贴东西
Alice: We're not allowed to stick stuff on the walls.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:但是不贴东西墙面巨空
Alice: But the walls look so empty without anything.
Alice:我就在想
Alice: I was thinking
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:偷偷的摁几个胶应该也不会被发现吧
Alice: Maybe if we secretly use some adhesive, no one will notice.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 是在二楼吃吗
Tasha: Are we eating on the second floor?
Tasha: 哎吃饭的呢
Tasha: Hey, where's the food?
Lucia: 这芒果有85.8克
Lucia: This mango weighs 85.8 grams.
Jake:这么重哎呦
Jake: That's heavy, wow.
Tasha: 你要开始转换率了吗
Tasha: Are you going to start converting now?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yep.
Alice:对干嘛呀
Alice: Yeah, what’s up?
Lucia: 不是是杨老板要开始转化他了
Lucia: No, Jake’s about to start converting him.
Tasha: 吃饭吗
Tasha: Are we eating?
Alice:要干嘛啊
Alice: What are we doing?
Jake:吃卤煮
Jake: Eating braised stew.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake:上楼吃卤煮
Jake: Going upstairs to eat braised stew.
Tasha: 你骗我
Tasha: You’re kidding me.
Jake:啊还有火烧
Jake: Ah, and there’s flatbread too.
Jake:火烧有奶了
Jake: The flatbread has milk in it now.
Jake:我还得出去一趟
Jake: I still need to go out once more.
Tasha: 行我不吃卤煮
Tasha: Fine, I won’t eat braised stew.
Alice:你要转化他干嘛
Alice: Why are you trying to convert him?
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 我们那天那个啥做甜点的说闹着玩了
Lucia: That day, the dessert maker was just joking around.
Lucia: 就是说看那一个芒果能削出多少来
Lucia: It was just to see how much we could peel off a mango.
Tasha: 肉
Tasha: Meat.
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
Lucia: 对不是是因为金康他头一回削的时候
Lucia: Yeah, because when Jincang peeled it for the first time...
Lucia: 但是对就这个芒果他皮比较粘肉
Lucia: But yeah, this mango’s skin is pretty sticky to the flesh.
Tasha: 边吃边削
Alice:啊
Lucia: 所以他削开
Lucia: 不是本来就很小吗
Lucia: 然后好多肉都粘在那个皮上
Lucia: 对然后然后听他说这怎么回事
Lucia: 我说正确打开方式是把那个皮剥开
Alice:是
Alice:这样划到的啊
Lucia: 然后把它吃掉
Lucia: 不是就我们就把那个皮上沾的都吃了
Lucia: 对所以我们就说
Lucia: 测测这转化率到底能有多少
Alice:上楼吧
Alice:哪个是丁老头
Lucia: 就是这个不
Lucia: 也不算丁老头
Lucia: 他跟丁老头是类似的画法
Lucia: 好像就那种
Lucia: 有个顺口溜画法
Alice:什么一个丁老头
Alice: What about an old man Ding?
Lucia: 对捡两个蛋什么的
Lucia: Yeah, picking up a couple of eggs or something.
Lucia: 我需要一个
Lucia: I need one.
Lucia: 充电宝
Lucia: A power bank.
Lucia: 让我看看他这有没有
Lucia: Let me see if he has one.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Lucia: 我需要一个充电宝
Lucia: I need a power bank.
Jake:没有了是吧
Jake: All out, right?
Tasha: what's this煎饼果子
Tasha: What's this, a Jianbing?
Lucia: 没看到那个太大了
Lucia: Didn't see that, it's too big.
Lucia: 我这裙子没有口袋
Lucia: My dress doesn't have pockets.
Jake:太大了这个
Jake: It's too big.
Alice:火烧
Alice: A grilled bun.
Shure: two
Shure: Two.
Jake:这个可能还行
Jake: This one might work.
Lucia: 这是充电宝啊
Lucia: Is this a power bank?
Jake:对你可以试试你插上之后过一会看看
Jake: Yeah, you can try it. Plug it in and check in a while.
Jake:他正在充电对
Jake: It's charging now, right.
Lucia: 试试看我好像把线放在这
Lucia: Let's see, I think I left the cable here.
Tasha: 吃饭了
Tasha: Time to eat.
Lucia: 是我吗是我的good
Lucia: Is it mine? Is it working? Good.
Shure: 可以上去吃
Shure: We can eat upstairs.
Shure: 准备吃上去
Shure: Let's get ready to eat upstairs.
Jake:我要转化帮我提谢谢
Jake: I need to convert, can you help me carry this? Thanks.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Jake:我转化一下
Jake: Let me convert.
Shure: go
Shure: Go.
Shure: 这个屋子味都杂了你知道吗
Shure: The smell in this room is all mixed up, you know?
Shure: 往右扭头是咖啡味
Shure: Turn right and it's coffee.
Shure: 往左扭头是大肠哈哈哈
Shure: Turn left and it's intestines, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina: 把我房间关起来
Katrina: Close my room.
Alice:有现成的可以喝一下的吗
Alice: Is there any ready-to-drink coffee?
Shure: 什么咖啡吗
Shure: What, coffee?
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Shure: 可以喝
Shure: You can drink it.
Alice:洗个杯子
Alice: Wash a cup.